[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشعوب
يرى فيها غصوننا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني موسى ستطره تنوء
بها الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الهوف
[موسيقى]
تجري على رسلها الدنيا ويتبعها راي بتعليل
مجراها ومعتقد
اعيا الفلاسفه الاحرار جهلهم ماذا يخبي
لهم في دفتيه غدو السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
المذيع هو اسم فاعل لفعل اذاع واذاع الخبر
اين شره واعلنه واذا عن نشره اي بثها عبر
الاذاعه المسموعه او المرئيه هذا عن
المهنه لكن ضيوع الاخبار او افشاءها ليس
قاصرا على من يظهر على الشاشه او يصل صوته
عبر الاثير يقول الشاعر وظننت ما اودعت في
بطن الثرى سرا وسرا لا يذاع مذاع
نقول اذاع السر او اذااع بالسر كما جاء في
قوله تعالى واذا جاءهم امر من الامن او
الخوف اذااعوا به واذاع الرجل بماله اي
ذهب به واستنفذه يقول الشاعر كتمت سجوف
الرقم ذائع حسنها واعدنا مكتوم الصبابه
ذائعا ورجل مذياع اي يبوح دائما بالاسرار
[موسيقى]
من جميل ما قيل في فضل الاعطاء قبل السؤال
قول سعيد بن العاص قبح الله المعروف اذا
لم يكن ابتداء من غير مساله فالمعروف عوض
عن مساله الرجل اذا بذل وجهه فقلبه خائف
وفرائسه ترعد وجبينه يرشح لا يدري يرجع
بنجح الطلب ام بسوء المنقلب
وقال اكثم ابن صيفي كل سؤال وان قل اكثر
من كل نوال وان جل وقال علي بن ابي طالب
رضي الله عنه لاصحابه من كانت له الي منكم
حاجه فليرفعها في كتاب لاصون وجوهكم عن
المساله وقال عبد العزيز بن مروان ما
تاملني رجلا قط الا سالته عن حاجته ثم كنت
من ورائها ويقول الشاعر ما ماء كفك ان
جهادت وان بخلت من ماء وجهي ياء افنيته
عوض
وقالوا من بذل اليك وجهه فقد وافاك حق
نعمته
[موسيقى]
يقول ابو نواس يقول والناطف في كفه من
يشتري الحلو من الحلو
الناطف في زمنهم سائل من المائعات
اشتهر كحلوى في العهد العباسي ضرب من
الحلوى التي تصنع من لوز وجوز وفستق
وكانوا يسمونه ايضا القبيط وهذا يعني ان
الناطف في زمانهم ليس الناطفا في زماننا
نطف اليوم يصنع من السمسم والسكر والنشاء
لتحليه كعك العيد
والجلاب ويقال ايضا جولاب ماء الورد شراب
من عسل او سكر معقود بوزنه او اكثر من ماء
الورد واصل الكلمه من الفارسيه كلاب كل
يعني الورد او الزهر واب هو الماء فهو ماء
الورد او ماء الزهر يقول ابن حجاج فنقطه
من دم اوداجه انفع لي من رطل جلابي
[موسيقى]
قال لقمان لابنه ان غايه الشرف والسادد في
الدنيا والاخره حسن العقل لان العبد اذا
حسن عقله غطى ذلك عيوبه واصلح مساويه ورضي
عنه خالقه وكفى بالمرء عقلا ان يسلم الناس
من شره وقال بعض الحكماء كل شيء يعز اذا
قل والعقل كلما كثر كان اعز
[موسيقى]
الخزاعي في واحده من قصائده الجميله
المؤلمه
غششت الهوى حتى تداعت اصوله بنا وابتدلت
الوصل حتى تقطع
وانزلت من بين الجوانح والحشا ذخيره ود
طال ما قد تمنا فلا تعدلني ليس لي فيك
مطمع تخرقت حتى لم اجد لك مرقعا فهبك يمين
استاكلت فاحتسبتها وجشمت قلبي قطعها فتشجع
هذه المرحله قد يصل اليها العاشق وهو في
قمه الياس والاحباط ولكنها راحه للعاشق
الا يقال الياس احدى الراحتين فاحدى
الراحتين ان يصل الى المحبوب والى ما
يبتغيه منه واحدى الراحتين ايضا او ثانيه
الراحتين ان يصل الى هذا الياس الذي يكون
مجبولا بالاسى والاحباط ولا ادري لماذا
تذكرت قول المتنبي كم قد قتلت وكم قد مت
عندكم ثم انتفضت فزال القبر والكفن
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل حال الجريظ دون القريض فما قصه
هذا المثل
الجريظ الغصه من الجرد وهو الريق يغص به
يقال جرض بريقه اي ابتلع ريقه على هم وحزن
ويقال مات فلان جريضا اي مغموما واما
القريض فهو الشعر كما تعلمون
ويضرب هذا المثل لمن تحقق له المراد بعد
فوات الاوان واصله ان رجلا كان له ولد نبغ
في الشعر فنهاه ابوه عن ذلك فجاش به صدره
ومرض حتى اشرف على الهلاك فاذن له ابوه
عندها في قول الشعر فقال هذا القول حال
الجريظ دون القريض
ويقول المثل ايضا حرك لها حوارها تحن فما
قصه هذا المثل
الحوار كما تعلمون ولد الناقه والجمع
القليل احوره والكثير حيران ولا يزال
حوارا حتى يفصل فاذا فصل عن امه فهو فصيل
ومعنى المثل ذكره بعض اشجانه يهج وهذا
المثل قال هو عمرو بن العاص لمعاويه حين
اراد ان يستنصر اهل الشام
[موسيقى]
يقول العرب تاكدت الشيء تاكدا اما قول
بعضهم اليوم تاكدت من الشيء فهذا خطا شائع
الفعل تاكد لم يرد في كلام العرب الا
بمعنى توكد فنقول تاكد الامر او توكد
الامر اي ثبت ثبوتا وثيقا وجاء في لسان
العرب وكذا الامر او العهد بمعنى اوثقه او
نقول وكد الامر بمعنى اوثقه
نقول تخرج فلان في الكليه الفلانيه ولا
نقول تخرج من الكليه لان تخرج هنا معناها
تادب فيه وتعلم فيه وتدرب في هذه الكليه
فلا نقول
من انه لا يتدرب منها وانما يتدرب فيها
الصواب ان نقول نرمي الى الاصلاح لا ان
نقول نهدف الى الاصلاح ما الفرق بينهما
هدف الى الشيء اي اسرع اليه وقاربه نقول
فلان هدف الى الخمسين اي انه قاربها في
حين ان الرميه الى الشيء لا يعني قرب
الوصول اليه واصابته انما قد يعني
الاجتهاد والسعي لاصابته
[موسيقى]
كان عبد الله بن عياش معروفا بالمنتوف
لماذا لانه كان ينتف لحيته مع برص يشكو
منه وكان الرجل من صحابه ابي جعفر المنصور
وكان محدثا راويه للاشعار والانساب وصاحب
نوادر قال له المنصور يوما لقد بغضت الي
صورتك عشرتك وحلفت بالله لان تفت شعره من
لحيتك لاقطعن بيدك فما كان من الرجل الا
ان اعفاها حتى اتصلت لا يملك ان يخالف
الخليفه ثم كان عند ابي جعفر يوما وحدثه
باحاديث استحسنها المنصور فقال له سل
حاجتك فقال نعم يا امير المؤمنين تقطعني
لحيتي افعل بها ما اريد فضحك المنصور وقال
قد فعلت
اذا كنت مطلعا على كتب الادب فقد تعلم ان
اقطعني او اقطع هو من الاقطاع وهو ما يهبه
ولي الامر من الارض او المال الثابت او
المنقول
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر ماذا قال الشعراء
في السيف
وفيما يلي استعرض معكم بعض ما وصلني من
مشاركاتكم هذه مشاركه من ياسمين تقول
دعوني اوفي السيف في الحرب حقه
واشرب من كاس المنيه صافيه ومن قال اني
سيد وابن سيد فسيفي وهذا الرمح عمي وخاليه
الله عنتره بن شداد طبعا
وايناس تقول ومن نعماء للمفضول الا كمثل
الحلي في السيف الكهامي يعني عندما تضع
حليا للسيف فانت لا تزيده شيئا لان جمال
السيف وبفعله وقوته بفعله
فهو يريد ان يقول ان هذا الممدوح انه لا
يحتاج الى شيء من النعمه لان النعمه منه
وفيه
الدكتور فيصل يقول قول ابي الطيب يمدح سيف
الدوله فلا تعجب ان السيوف كثيره ولكن سيف
الدوله اليوم
واحدوا
المتنبي العظيم دكتور مسرقع يقول حتى رجعت
اقلامي قوائل لي المجد للسيف ليس المجد
للقلم
اكتب بنا ابدا بعد الكتاب به فانما نحن
للاسياخ كالخدم
هذا اذا
مشاركه ايضا من خطاب الجبوري يقول ومن شده
الباس الذي بمهند تسيل دماء الخصم قبل
التصادم جميل هذا المعنى
وعلي يقول العزه تحت ظلال السيف العز تحت
ظلال السيف معدنه فاطلب بسيفك عزا اخر
الابد
رغد تقول هذا بيت من الابيات الشعبيه
ابيات النبطيه يقول لا تمدح الصانع على
صنعه السيف امدح يمينا باللي قال اوحت به
من الابيات القريبه الى القلب صراحه
براء عاشور يقول لعب فيهم المفروض انك
وضعت الواو في البدايه يا براء يقول ولا
عيب فيه من غير ان سيوفهم بهن فلول من
انقراع الكتائب
اما انا فاذا سمحتم لي بالمشاركه فقد كتبت
بيتا
في السيف اقول فيه
السيف يعرف بالتجريب جوهره وانت قبل فراق
الغمد معروف
اشكر لكم مشاركاتكم هذه واذكركم بان تضعوا
اسم تاملات الجزيره عند نهايه كل مشاركه
من اجل سهوله الوصول اليها واعاده تدويرها
والاستفاده منها
[موسيقى]
ما من فيلسوف عربي اثار الجدل واشعل
المعارك الفكريه مثلما فعل ابن رشد
في الغرب احتفى به كثيرون وراوا ان
مؤلفاته كانت احد روافد النهضه العقليه في
الغرب
وفي الشرق ادت معاركه الفكريه وخلافاته مع
فلاسفه المسلمين وعلماء الكلام والفقهاء
الى حرق كتبه وانزواء افكاره في جانب بعيد
عن التيار الرئيسي للفكر العربي والاسلامي
ولد ابو الوليد محمد بن احمد بن رشد في
مدينه قرطبه حاضره الاندلس في عام 520
للهجره ونشا في بيت عريق في العلم والادب
كان والده قاضيا وفقيها له مجلس يدرس فيه
في جامع قرطبه الكبير
درس ابن رشد الفقه والتفسير والطب
والرياضيات والفلك والفلسفه واستظهر موطا
الامام مالك على والده الفقيه ابي القاسم
مارس الطب وتولى القضاء في اشبيليه وقرطبه
وامتدت مؤلفاته لتشمل الفلسفه وعلم النفس
والفقه واللغه وعلم الكلام والفيزياء
والجغرافيا والقانون وبلغ ما وصلنا من
كتبه ثمانيه وخمسين مؤلفا من ابرز ما قدمه
ابن رشد للثقافتين العربيه والغربيه شرحه
الوافي لفلسفه ارسطو فتناول كل ما استطاع
ان يحصل عليه من مؤلفاته وشروحها بالدراسه
العميقه المبنيه على التحليل الدقيق
والنقد العميق لافكاره بعدما اطلع على كل
ما ترجم من كتب اليونان التي ضاع اغلبها
فيما بعد لذلك فابن رشد صاحب الفضل الاكبر
في الحفاظ على فلسفه ارسطو وقراءتها نقديا
حتى انه لقب في الاوساط العلميه الغربيه
بالشارح
وكان لاعجابه العظيم بمنطق ارسطو دور كبير
في نقده لافكار الفلاسفه العرب من امثال
الفارابي وابن سينا اللذين سار في نقدهما
على نفس منهج نقد ارسطو لافلاطون بل وحاول
ان يدمج فلسفه ارسطو مع الفكر الاسلامي
معتبرا ان الفلسفه لا تتعارضوا مع الدين
بل انكليهما طريقان لنفس الغايه وهو الامر
الذي جعله يختلف مع كثيرا من فقهاء عصره
واختلف في مسائل كثيره مع الاشاعره كما لم
يقر الكثير من افكار المعتزله الذين مثلوا
اتجاها باطنيا في الفكر الاسلامي من
مؤلفاته في الفقه بدايه المجتهد ونهايه
المقتصد ومناهج الادله اما كتابه فصل
المقال فيما بين الحكمه والشريعه من اتصال
فقد اكد فيه على اهميه التفكير التحليلي
في تفسير القران مخالفا علم الكلام في
عصره ومعليا من قيمه البرهان العقلي
ويعد كتابه الكليات موسوعه لعلوم الطب في
وقته كما شرح ارجوزه ابن سينا في الطب
وكانت له ابحاثه في مجال الفلك حيث قدم
نقدا لنظريه بطليموس وصفا للقمر اضاف لما
كان معروفا وقتها بل انه اكتشف كويكبا لم
يكن معروفا من خلال رصد فلكيا اجراه في
المغرب وكان حينها في سن الخامسه والعشرين
واضافه الى كل ذلك كانت له اسهامات في
الرياضيات ويعتقد انه اول من اقترح مفهوم
القصور الذاتي في الفيزياء
واجتهد في تفسير ظاهره قوس قزح اما اشهر
كتبه ومعاركه الفكريه
فكان كتاب تهافت التهافت الذي رد فيه على
كتاب الغزالي تهافت الفلاسفه والكتابان
يقدمان عرضا فكريا شائقا لمدرستين
متعارضتين في النظر الى الفكر والوصول الى
الحقيقه
بالرغم من انتمائه لعائله تولت مناصب
الفقه والقضاء وتوليه هو نفسه مناصب
القضاء في كل من اشبيليا وقرطبه وبالرغم
انه كانت طبيب الخاص للخليفه الموحد ابو
يعقوب يوسف في مراكش وتكليفه بمهام سياسيه
بحكم قربه من البلاط لم يتحرج من ان تكون
له ارائه السياسيه التي تحمل افكارا
اصلاحيه لواقع الناس في الاندلس فقد
ركز على اهميه الممارسه السياسيه بمعنى ان
تتطابق افعال الحاكم مع اقواله وفي ذلك
يقول عند الحديث عن التحول الى المدينه
الفاضله بان ذلك يكون بالاعمال الصالحه لا
بالاراء الحسنه وانت تلمس ذلك في مدننا
وبالجمله فلم يصعب على من كملت لديه اقوال
اجزاء الفلاسفه والطلع على طرق تحول المدن
ان يرى انها لم تاول نحو الافضل بالاراء
وحدها
بقي بن رشد في بلاط الموحدي في مراكش حتى
توفي الخليفه وخلفه ولده المنصور الذي غضب
على ابن رشد واتهمه بالزندقه ونفاه الى
قريه اليسان في الاندلس والتي كان يسكنها
اغلبيه من اليهود
واحرق الخليفه كتبه بل واصدر منشورا يحرم
قراءه كتب الفلسفه لكنه بعد اعوام راجع
نفسه وعفا عنه فعاد ابن رشد الى مراكش حيث
توفي
ودفن في عام
595 للهجره ثم نقل رفاته فيما بعد الى
مسقط راسه في قرطبه
من اشهر اقواله من العدل ان ياتي الرجل من
الحجج لخصومه بمثل ما ياتي لنفسه ويقول
الحسن ما حسنه العقل
والقبيح ما قبحه العقل
ويقول لو سكت من لا يعرف لقل الخلاف
الحسن ما حسنه العقل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان احد الاصدقاء مسافرا خارج الدوحه وانا
كنت في الدوحه ثم لما قفل عائدا صدف ان
سافرت في نفس اليوم متجها الى لبنان فكتبت
اليه مهنئا ومعتذرا
هنئت نفسي فيك والاوطان اهلا وسهلا بالذي
وافانا نورت مهتما النفوس بعوده كالغيث
روت مهما ظمان روحي بدوحتكم وحول دياركم
لو كان جسمي قاصدا لبنان السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]